bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
de sport show hebdomadaire invité
aujourd'hui est une jeune nageuse
vous avez déjà certainement vu son
sourire à la télévision ou dans les
journaux régionaux c'est roxana
maracineanu à 17 ans il est déjà
plusieurs fois championne de france
et puis depuis l'été dernier elle
détient le record du 100 m dos le record
de france
et puis avec quelle à ses côtés lyonnais
leurs terres l'entraîneur de mulhouse
olympique natation pour nous parler un
petit peu de sa progression
sport show hebdo c'est aussi toute
l'actualité du week end avec bien sûr
eric au sommaire le carton du racing oui
il ya le résultat mais aussi cette
manière que les 20000 spectateurs en vue
vendredi soir au stade de la meinau 6 1
face à sochaux nous reviendrons
longuement bien sûr sur cette rencontre
on verra également la désillusion
mulhousienne hier soir dans les ardennes
face à charleville une défaite 4 à 2 on
la verra en images des images de nos
confrères de reims et puis nous verrons
la soirée basket ball avec des défaites
celle de la sig en images la défaite du
fc mulhouse inattendue face à berre et
puis la victoire la première pour
patrick lazare il s'agit là des filles
du racing club de strasbourg face à
l'équipe de tarbes et puis des images de
volley ball
nous irons cette fois ci dans le sud de
l'alsace où ça marche très fort en
nationale 3 c'est l'équipe de l as saint
louis neuweg leader invaincu qui
recevait hier soir lui asenga ni naïve
et qui est toujours invaincu et puis on
verra également des images de squash là
c'est le début du championnat de france
par équipe une équipe de féminines de
l'as town squash de strasbourg et puis
nous terminons avec des images de canaux
de kayak-polo un sport tout à fait
particulier qui se passe dans l'eau sur
la piscine de schiltigheim ce week-end
claude vous y étiez là aussi s'agit de
champion de france mais on reste dans
l'eau pour découvrir un peu mieux notre
invité roxana alors roxana une saison 92
soit qu'on peut dire qu'elle a été
magnifique et je crois qu'on peut dire
aussi que ce record de france c'est
quand même le summum
ouais
un record qui était vieux de 12 ans ça
fait quel effet quand même de le battre
c'est assez émouvant parce que ça
faisait donc longtemps qu'il n'avait pas
été battu
et en tant que nouvelle encore voilà
vous avez besoin vous l'avez améliorée
vous avez une 0 4 75 6 mai ma mémoire
est bonne vous l'avait amélioré de
combien ce record il était à une 5 2
donc ça fait à peu près une demi seconde
de pouvoir tout de suite les images
comme ça vous vous replongez vous
souvenez l'heure la date c'était un même
si le 19 juillet à peu près vers quelle
heure c'était dans l'après midi et à ce
moment là alors qu'est ce qu'on ressent
sur sur le moment quand on m'a touché là
c'est très impressionnant quand tout le
monde commençait à punir et consorts de
l'eau d'abord je me rendais pas compte
vraiment je savais que j'étais
susceptible de le battre mais une fois
qu'on voit le temps sur le chronomètre
ça fait ça fait très impressionnant quoi
quand sort de l'autre on applaudit on se
rend compte qu'on a battu un record qui
était très important
c'est ça fait vraiment une grande
émotion
lionel vous êtes aux côtés de roxana son
entraîneur est ce que vous sincèrement
que vous attendiez ce jour-là à ce
qu'elle fasse un tel exploit une telle
performance
nous savons tous à mulhouse et que
roxanne a beaucoup de qualités mais vous
savez pour battre un record de france
est pour bat un record en général il
faut réunir beaucoup de paramètres qu'on
ne maîtrise pas toujours et
parfois il faut un petit peu un petit
peu actif à quatre facteurs chance même
dans l'espoir chronométrique et là sur
la roxane a réuni toutes les conditions
pour battre ce record et je dois dire
qu'à mulhouse tout le monde on a été
très très heureux alors maintenant je
crois que disons si on prend les dix
vingt dernières années les records man
ou woman de france en alsace
y en a pas tant que ça finalement vous
êtes du nombre oui il j'en ai battus a
personnellement 84 il y à thierry pata
de notre club qui en a battu un autre il
me semble que dans les années 70 jean
noël reinhardt a battu aussi un record
de france on peut les compter sur les
doigts d'une main
alors il ya un facteur dont on va parler
aussi roxana vous vous êtes venu en
france à sept ans vous êtes d'origine
roumaine et donc vous êtes venu en
france avec vos parents avec votre frère
est ce que je vous propose pour vous
téléspectateurs pour mieux connaître
roxana et bien cette feuilleter un petit
peu l'album de famille en compagnie de
votre père qui raconte un petit peu
votre progression
on était entrés en france
j'essaye de prendre des contacts avec
des petites club où on était installés à
vouloir 85,87 appelé donc vous vous
doutez salehi 6,87 à cause de travail
que j'ai trouvé de travail ici ici j'ai
pris contact comme j'ai vu des belles
piscines et bons résultats j'ai pris
contact avec pierre jubil a été convoqué
ou file a fait une essai il a été un peu
étonnée de ces qualités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous doutiez qu'elle
allait arriver à ce niveau vous vous
espériez même qu'elle allait arriver à
ce niveau j'espère que niveau régionale
ipr arrivé je croyais pas que peu ont
fait partie de l'équipe de france d être
visages et des sélectionnés dans
l'équipe des fins ou despatie sco
l'olimpiade et qui fait que tu aies la
vedette ras lanouf
alors qui des deux petites erreurs la
commencer à zéro au niveau la main c'est
ouvrir qu'à sion pas à pas grand chose
est il du bus c'est être aidé dans mon
avis c'est très dur pour elle s'est
intégrée
il a bien réussi à passer le plein
d'obstacles
grâce à son travail son volonté
[Musique]
aulas
oksana sept ans vous avez fait votre
premier plouf dans une piscine c'est à
cette époque là vous vous disiez mon la
natation c'est bien ou c'est parce que
mes parents me emmène que j'aime ça non
d'abord ça a été c'est mes parents en
roumanie en général tout le monde fait
un peu de sport vu que les études le
permettent on finit on a tout l'après
midi de libre alors faut bien occuper
les enfants on va aux sports alors mon
père m'a inscrit à la natation et à
partir de là bon j'ai fait un peu de
compétition là bas et une fois venu en
france je donc j'ai arrêté pendant
quelques années j'ai recommencé et c'est
ça qui me fait aussi comme disait mon
père jamais - non que j'aurais imaginé
qu'on puisse comme on est venu ici on
n'avait rien on était vraiment rien quoi
et là maintenant avoir avoir c'est tout
ça c'est justement l'intégration dont
vous parliez pas du tout français quand
vous êtes arrivé ce que ça ça a été
quelque chose de difficile parce qu'on
vous voie au lycée montaigne maintenant
là ça a l'air vraiment mettre super avec
les copains et les copines mais ça peut
être pas été toujours aussi facile ça va
mon et parents ont toujours été là pour
pour m'inciter à m'intégrer bien et puis
j'avais autour de moi des gens qui
étaient assez compréhensive déjà au
début quand quand je savais pas bien le
français j'ai appris assez vite à parler
français mais c'est aussi grâce à mes
professeurs que j'avais qui m'expliquait
bien qu'ils étaient attentifs avec moi
et alors là ça j'ai bien j'ai entendu
dire que vos notes au bac de français
étaient pas fabule du tout vu combien
l'an dernier au bac de français à l'oral
et à l'écrit c'est bien
je crois qu'on peut en souhaiter autant
à pas mal de lycéens et de lycéennes et
vous lionel vous souvenez de l'arrivée
de roxana au mulhouse olympique natation
je m'en souviens je m'en souviens très
bien oui je me rappelle très bien quand
la première fois qu'elle est venue
s'entraîner dans notre groupe
cette petite plus légère en voyait
presque à travers il n'y avait pas grand
chose sur la sur les os et je dois dire
que ça fait partie un petit peu de ses
qualités
c'est une fille qui est très souple très
légère et qui tire parti d'un rapport
poids puissance comme on pourrait dire
phénoménal bon bah on va y revenir si
c'était un petit peu la contradiction
parce que quand on voit les nageurs
actuelle ce sont de grands gabarits
oksana prouve qu'on peut avec des
qualités je dirais par athlétique
masquer les âmes et les qualités
physiques moindre réussir bien sûr bien
sûr mais d'un côté il ya les qualités
athlétiques et de l'autre côté les
qualités psychique et de motivation est
là je dois dire que vous tombez aussi
sur un phénomène exceptionnel
elle est très très serré verrez aussi
sexy elle est motivée
comme peu de gens le sont je souhaitais
en histoire je ne pourrais pas vous le
dire exactement mais c'est une grande
partie de sa réussite
alors dans la série souvenirs on va on
va écouter laurent hors terre votre papa
et qui est aussi le directeur du midi
olympique natation qui lui se souvient
aussi des tout premiers des toutes
premières images de roxana quand il l'a
vu arriver
oui il m'a tout de suite fait ancien
mari pierre c'est vraiment ça c'était
une petite grenouille comme marie pierre
elle avait
neuf ou dix ans elle était pleine de vie
pleine de joie très minces comme elle
est encore et sautillant gambadant dans
la piscine elle m'a fait penser à marie
pierre qui a presque dix ans de plus
qu'elle et j'ai retrouvé tout de suite
cette image ça m'a frappé d'entrée c'est
vrai qu'en sont je trouve qu'elle me
ressemble à ses dents dans les faits le
chemin 4 qu'elle veuille magique elle
sait ce qu'elle veut faire
pourquoi elle le fait ce qu'elle veut
faire mais sinon c'est vrai qu'elle est
beaucoup plus vif d'esprit et beaucoup
plus comment dire
extravertie que moi même mal par rapport
à son âge on vous voit souvent ensemble
quand vous nagez vous êtes à la pause
vous êtes en train de papoter toutes les
deux
ceux de bonnes copines oui c'est vrai on
s'entend très bien ensemble et puis bon
peut-être que le fait que j'ai déjà vécu
un peu ce qu'elle avec escales en train
de vivre la recherche peut-être un peu
chez moi des expériences et des réponses
à nos questions
et puis mais c'est une fille assez ville
qui pose toujours plein de questions et
qui a toujours tout savoir alors elle
vient de chez ceux qui peuvent lui
répondre alors que ça va c'est quoi
toutes les questions que vous lui posez
à marc hutter
c'est vrai que partager l'expérience de
marie-pierre c'est c'est très
intéressant de partager aussi ce qu'on
éprouve donc on a quand on a des
résultats à savoir parce qu'on a des
émotions qui sont assez personnelle et
quand quelqu'un d'autre les a eus avant
nous c'est c'est important de pouvoir en
parler avec quelqu'un doute de les
partager et je bénéficie aussi de 2
c'est vrai que son caractère et et c'est
vraiment un exemple pour moi nos points
de vue de volonté et d'entraînement
comment elle réussit à s'entraîner même
maintenant encore alors l'entraînement
c'est précisément un des moments
capitaux dans la vie d'un nageur c'est
quelque chose de pour nous qui regardons
ça de l'extérieur ça a l'air d'être
faramineuses voix des longueurs qui
s'additionnent des longueurs de bassin
on va d'ailleurs en voir des images
puisqu'on est venu vous surprendre un
jour à la piscine de l'illberg
c'est dur rappelez-nous lyonnais en quoi
ça consiste pour pour oksana par exemple
l'entraînement hebdomadaire quotidien
plutôt les kilomètres quotidiennement
elle nage entre
10 à 15 voire parfois un peu plus de
kilomètres fait deux séances par jour
elles ont fait une le matin avant les
coûts généralement c'est la séance est
longue donc à 6h30 du matin 5h10 qu'à
5h30 ce matin césar et denis sylvain
l'origine les horaires parfois en
milliers d'oeufs et de toute façon tous
les soirs et donc ça demande une
certaine volonté une capacité
d'organisation
propre à notre sport et qui développe
qui fait moi je crois des gens très
équilibré et
roxana on est un peu l'exemple si on
veut réussir dans le sport en général
mais surtout natation il faut être très
équilibré très bien dans sa peau alors
on aurait voulu savoir aussi pourquoi
roxana finalement se spécialise dans le
dock est ce qui fait qu elle est plutôt
bonne dans cette discipline là mais je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que sa
morphologie est un peu unique quasiment
dans les annales de la natation
française
elle est très légère
et pourtant elle a quand même une
puissance étonnante dans ses bras la des
segments des bras assez long
mais je crois que pour l'instant elle
est en deux ans de nhk très vite mais
vous savez moi je suis très ambitieux
pour elle et désespère pas un jour
d'avoir un avis pour être aussi parmi
les meilleures nageuses françaises vous
roccella de nager sans voir où vous
allez ça vous dérange pas si c'est
simple permettant d'être surtout quand
un agent long nez en l'air libre on voit
pas pour pas très bien se repérer mais
le dos j'aime bien mais je compte bien
passer aussi aux 4 nages donc voilà
alors vous disiez vous tout à l'heure
que marie pierre est un exemple pour
vous alors j'aimerais tout de suite
qu'on découvre comment vos camarades de
club vous perçoivent elle a fait des
progrès sensationnels il faut dire ce
qui est il ya deux ans elle était encore
finaliste finalistes de chamakh france
elle se retrouve encore woman de france
du 100 m dos bon les orties s'ébattent
et nous permet elle motive
on est très fier pour elle en est
content et puis on essaie de suivre la
même voie
on a en plaisir à s'entraîner avec elle
et partager ça sans succès ses résultats
on est très content pour elle surtout
quand tu la vois
parallèlement à toi progresser qu'est-ce
que ça t'inspire disons que j'ai
progressé un peu plus avant noël et puis
là maintenant c'est elle qui progressent
alors c'est un peu on pourrait spa en
même temps mais toutes les deux on
progresse à des saisons différentes
c'est ça me
c'est sûr qu'elle est championne de
france pas moi mais bon ça motive un peu
on est un bon petit groupe là on rigole
bien
elle en fait partie avec d'autres et
puis on est à plusieurs là on est tout
le temps ensemble et puis heureusement
que sur l'entraînement des fois c'est
tellement dur que faut bien rigoler un
peu quand même
est ce que ça vous semble pesant pour
vous d'être presque maintenant une enfin
un des leaders de ce club à 17 ans être
comme ça une locomotive d'un grand club
de natation ces lois en tant que je me
sens pas tellement locomotive du club
mais c'est vrai que ça mais ça met de
l'ambiance et ça motive le groupe de
savoir que qu'on peut faire enfin de
voir ces choses à apporter à notre
portée comme moi j'ai vu marie pierre
qui était championne je me suis dit je
peux le faire alors peut-être que
d'autres nous voyons enfin il disparaît
mais c'est vrai donc avec laurence on
est peut-être les espoirs du club et que
c'est vrai que c'est bien l'ambiance du
club bel et bien seul
[Musique]